pour ou contre un couple d'hommes temps
d'als le sondage c'est parti le freinage
du post la nouvelle saison de d'als de
danse avec les stars fait beaucoup
parler cette année
en effet depuis le 27 août une polémique
a éclaté à propos de l'humoriste jean
phi janssen et oui il a regardé il a
parlé dans les grosses têtes sur rtl il
a parlé de danse avec les stars il a dit
qu'il voulait danser avec un homme mais
que tf1 n'avait pas voulu non
franchement jean marc qui se ressemblent
pas du tout c'est bien alors il a dû sa
non non sur rtl et après donc les f1
desmontils tout de suite ça fait un
ramdam pas possible vous allez nous dire
ce que vous en pensez et si vous avez
des infos alors pour ou contre un couple
d'hommes donald pourrions-nous vite et
vous nous dites c'est bon c'est le
sondage c'est parti c'est juste de la
danse après si la personne est
homosexuel ou ce qu'elle veut on s'en
fout c'est juste de la danse qu'est ce
que ça peut faire
ah oui je trouve ça de revoir deux
amoureux ça dépend comment ils dansent
si jamais ils dansaient vraiment comme
aux hommes et femmes sa peau je pense
qu'il faut qu'on évolue quand même au
niveau des idées des moeurs de chacun on
a déjà vu plusieurs fois de zones denses
et ça peut être aussi très jolie et je
pense que l'aménageur d'aujourd'hui
il est totalement prête pour ça la
définition de danse avec les stars c'est
le couple homme femme en tant que à la
faute et spectateurs et que citoyen ça
me gêne pas du tout voire deux hommes
danser ensemble dans une émission de
télé j'ai aucun souci là-dessus
eh bien pourquoi 71% contre halak 9%
alors on va regarder les propos de jean
phi janssen dans les grosses têtes sur
rtl à propos d'app se regarde j'avais
demandé avec un danseur ce que je
trouvais ça novateur qui bat pour que
tout le monde y sais qui je suis j
pourquoi que je n'entrais pas qu'un
danseur les audi no la ménagère est pas
prête gymase et cuisez-les à la ménagère
est pas prés mâles légère et pas prête à
voir ça je dis moi s'il faut que je mets
une robe chemise robail et non du coup
donc juré j'aurai une dame
voilà donc donc alors j'en fis janssen a
rétropédalé derrière puisque tf1 aclasta
maison si jean pigeon scènes de danse si
jean fils en scène de danse et qu'un
homme il le peut il n'avait jamais
exprimé clairement ce désir donc nous
avions programmé une femme nous allons
proposer à l'humoriste un changement de
partenaire s'il le désire et que j'en
fis a tweeté ensuite que tout le monde
se rassure ce qui a été dit aux grosses
têtes à ce sujet n'est que de l'humour
et rien de l'humour
voilà on pense que jean fille et un
garçon très l'andi a voulu voilà ne pas
m'être tf1 dans la panade
alors à vous vous êtes contre benjamin
castaldi contre un couple parfait
d'hommes suis content c'est quoi parce
que quand on pose la question déjà pour
moi c'est un problème
un homme peut danser avec un homme une
femme est une femme le poser la question
s'est isolé s'est montrée du doigt pour
cette raison là je suis content qu'on
ait posé la question de ce tout jean be
vous êtes contre oui je suis content
parce que je trouve à stigmatiser ça va
desservir la cause entre entre eux avec
un minuscule mais je trouve parce que
voilà les gens ne vous voir que ça ceux
qui trouvent ça normal ne vont pas
réagir ceux qui sont contre dans se
déchaîner sur les réseaux pour dire que
c'est pas normal et c'est il trouve ça
pas faire du bien il faudrait mettre à
ce moment là que des hommes et des
hommes des femmes et des femmes fait une
émission spéciale est ce qu'on voit
c'est que c'est vrai qu est ce que vous
pensez que c'est vrai que tf1 refusez
vous avez n'ai rien fait pour son tf1 a
refusé bien chaud que oui non peut-être
a refusé et derrière rick les ménagères
est pas prêt et total est en forme c'est
totalement vrai et renforcer la ménagère
et vous vous avez effectivement même si
c'est pas normal encore aujourd'hui
évidemment que tes fans peuvent pas
prendre le risque maintenant de faire ça
évidemment chacun d'où vous a déjà
proposé dans sa question
j'appuie je me souviens tu avais dit non
pourquoi
ben parce que j'étais déjà en train de
faire mes tournées à moi et ma famille
dit sur elle parle autant que tu as du
train
rien bien c'est ce que c'est oui
isabelle mais moi je suis très ami avec
jean py janssen bas quand j'ai entendu
un énorme et vous mentir avoue isabelle
valette dans l'émission il ne m'a jamais
menti et alors effectivement une femme
complète la ville en veux à tes fins et
non pas d'avoir d'avoir rétropédaler
comme tu dis parce qu'ils ont jamais
rétropédaler c'est le lendemain sans lui
en parler de dire ah non non mais non
mais si vous dans ses économies dans ce
qui ne va pas je vous fais du gainage je
préfère le simple fait qu tf1 prennent
le temps que tu as un communiqué ça veut
dire qu'ils ont subis tu dis rien je
vous ai rencontre oui moi je suis contre
pour nous autres à celle que vous n'êtes
pas évoqué c'est qu'en réalité la danse
à sedan c'est évidemment à deux lyonnais
qui dirige et l'autre qui a dirigé ghana
qui fait des portes et l'autre qui fait
déporter donc ça implique forcément qui
est un qui dirige et l'autre grosso modo
qui est un homme et une femme alors et
on revient à des îles dans sexe alors il
ya un ami un homme au vert écoute moi
aurons bien entendu quelques mais
stigmatise des hétéros devises alors qui
fait l'homme qui fait la femme phrase
quand on aimerait la raison chef qu'on
entendait à 30 ans chez tous les gays de
ce qui vous regarde et vado donc celui
qui porte aussi bien porté il ya la
famille à l'homme
or un couple homosexuel c'est pas une
femme et un homme ces deux hommes mais
donc ça va montrer tout ce qu'on ne pas
montrer nous sommes au cfai rien d'autre
pas d'accord et ce que dit ma dent alors
d'abord en italie qu un pays beaucoup
plus conservateur que nous il ya eu un
couple d'hommes et c'est un carton
absolu et ça n'a pas du tout choquée
l'année zéro en finale
non absolument et moi je crois d'abord
que c'était une boutade de et oui le
jour finit donc ce qu'il y avait oui
c'est l'italie c'était une boutade
nominés dans les grosses têtes il est
provocateur le témoin n'a besoin que tu
ais je crois pas
enfin d'un point de vue totalement
cynique marketing de tf1 vous croyez que
tf1 aurait fait l'erreur aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'air du temps par rapport au
mariage pour tous à dire de dire tu ne
peux pas danser avec un homme c'est
interdit théo on peut pas dire vidéo car
sur les infos qui connaît vraiment les
médias comme personne théaux peut pas
dire que c'est des surcoûts navale quand
on regarde un extrait c'est vrai qu'on
se sent vraiment que c'est sur le ton
anecdotique on voit que sérieusement moi
je pense que même lui dans son côté
personnel ils avaient l'intention de
danser avec un homme à ce que ben voilà
baptisé quand il dit ça y est on est
dans les temps
oui moi je suis évidemment four parce
que je pense que tf1 a une carte à jouer
là dessus étant donné qu'ils n'ont pas
sur le casting si l'on pas de là en ce
moment ils n'ont pas de casting fort et
donc que pamela anderson
donc ils ont tout à jouer sur les
évolutions sociales s'ils veulent être
fort là dessus qu'il soit fort là dessus
on a en 2018 on n'est pas en 1920 jeff
jaffe jean marc borello alors tu aurais
fait danse avec les stars
non il n'ya pas mélanger vie c'est inné
non moi je suis partie en vacances avec
jean phi encore oui et on en avait parlé
avant que tout ça ça ça sorte et
m'arrête toujours dit qu'ils étaient
très contentes danse avec une femme
et donc j'ai parlé avec lui par texto et
vous a jamais menti sans fiche enseigne
ne veux même berne à tous donc voilà
j'ai discuté avec lui il m'a dit oui
c'était juste une vanne et puis après ça
s'enflamme
en fait ce qui est pire c'est la réponse
de thé bah oui c'est vrai qu'avec ses
choix oui il n'avait dit elle c'est
drôle parce que fais tu dis ça mais si
c'est pas un problème d'abord pourquoi
ils n'ont jamais fait
regarde comme si c'était naturel dit je
vais plus en plus jamais ménagé les pros
mais jamais la première chaîne d'europe
même s'il a beaucoup chuté qui ne vit
que des pubs est une chaîne commerciale
ne prendra le risque de perdre autant de
autant antennes seraient dans le mettant
deux hommes
on aimerait en italie le fait qu'en
france ils veulent pas le faire
on ne sait pas voilà merci alors vous
l'avez dit donc voilà les gens sont
plutôt va revoir le sondage donc voilà
un impôt montre un couple d'hommes dans
danse avec les stars 71 % des gens sont
pour et 29 % son conte cali vous êtes
pour vous aussi
moi je suis pour mais à smara faut
revoir les codes de la danse suis
d'accord un petit peu avec mathieu
pensait ces sondages c'est comme quand
on demande aux gens qu est ce que vous
les voir à la télévision sur notre
important des gens qui veulent voir des
documentaires l'intellectuel et arte et
la réalité c'est qu'ils regardent nous
alors on n'a pas lâché on a un push je
m'ajuste s'arrêter un petit truc
par exemple moi je suis une danseuse
j'adore danser je danse avec des gens
que je ne connais pas et toi en mars que
j'adore à laquelle arrive dans la rue
c'est à dire que quand je vais dans des
soirées ou des trucs salsa ou machin je
danse avec les gens donc il n'ya pas de
quoi par exemple avec la danse être
jaloux parce que pour moi la danse c'est
de l'art et ça n'a rien à voir avec la
sexualité ni avec la séduction ni quoi
donc ça n'a rien à voir et
l'homosexualité non plus ce qui est beau
dans la danse de couple c'est de voir
une paire de danseurs qui a choisi une
paire de danseurs de 2,2 genre n'avait
compris avec des avec des corps
différents des capacités différentes
sayad économe et la famille de couple
mais merci merci c'est une et l'aria
rien à moins que la section j'ai bien
qu'il faut j'ai pas compris vous avez
dansé